Welcome to PyMOL 101 with Molecular Memory!
In this lesson, we’ll explore the less active
conformation of phosphofructokinase bound
to an inhibitor.
We’ll use the inhibitor to generate a binding
site, instead of selecting residues given
to us in a manuscript, like we did in Lesson
2.
This is helpful when we may not have access
to an article.
Load the biological assembly of 6pfk in PyMOL.
File, get PDB, 6pfk, assembly 1.
Then, color by chain with CPK coloring and
display the sequence.
Scroll until you see the three letter codes
for the inhibitor molecules.
Notice the PGA ligands have taken on the color
of a chain that they’re close to.
We’ll model the interactions of just one
of the ligands.
Let’s select the cyan PGA, this light blue
green one here.
The letters sele pop up—in Lesson 2, we
learned to rename selections to save them.
A, rename.
Delete the letters sele that come up in the
upper left of the structure viewer window.
Type inhibitor and press enter.
Now I’ll click in the blank space to make
sure I don’t add anything unwanted to this
selection.
Let’s zoom in on the inhibitor: A, zoom.
I’ll use the pinch motion on my trackpad
to zoom out a bit—if you’re using a mouse,
right click will zoom.
There’s a too much clipping to really see
the binding site, so I’ll adjust that by
running two fingers up and down the trackpad.
Now, we can see the inhibitor is actually
binding between two chains of the protein.
If we want to focus on just the parts of the
structure the ligand is interacting with,
we can hide the other chains.
This isn’t 100% necessary here, but I really
want to show you some of the options in the
mouse control menu.
Click where it says Selecting Residues, and
the menu changes.
Let’s stop on chains.
Click on the inhibitor and two chains in the
structure viewer.
You can also select by clicking in the sequence
display menu.
Zoom out a bit, and then next to SELE, hide
, unselected.
Now, we’re going to copy the inhibitor selection
and modify it.
Inhibitor, A, duplicate.
A new selection, sel01, pops up.
We’ll turn this into the binding site, so
let’s rename it “binding”.
To select nearby residues: A, modify, around,
residues within 4 angstroms to capture all
hydrogen bonding amino acids.
If you choose a 5 angstrom sphere, that will
capture residues that may be interaction through
van der Waals interactions too.
Now, show sticks and zoom in on the binding
site.
To select binding site water molecules only,
we can modify the binding site selection we
just made.
Duplicate the selection called binding.
Rename sel02 to active water, A, rename, delete
SELE, type active water.
Now: Action button, modify, restrict, to solvent.
And let’s show these as spheres.
Time for some adjustments.
The water spheres are large and obscuring
the active site.
Resize them using a preset.
A, preset, ball and stick.
The inhibitor’s cyan carbons are blending
in with some of the binding site residues.
Let’s recolor them: C, by element, and I’ll
select this one with white carbons.
Now, to add some interactions!
Inhibitor, A button, find, polar contacts.
There are a bunch of choices here, but let’s
just choose “to any atoms”.
And we can indeed see interactions with both
protein chains!
If we’d like, we can change the line color,
let’s try magenta.
And as we’re getting closer to a publication-quality
image, let’s go ahead and change the background
to white.
Display dropdown, background, white.
If we want to remove the nearby residues that
aren’t making polar contacts, we can, even
though they’re close enough to have van
der Waals interactions with the ligand.
First, we need to change our mouse control
menu back to the default “residues”.
Click here in the mouse control menu until
it reads “residues”.
Now, click on “binding” in the names panel.
Carefully deselect any residues that don’t
have dotted lines going to them by clicking
on them.
You’ll need to rotate and zoom while doing
this.
And if you accidentally deselect something
you didn’t mean to, just click on it again
to add it back.
OK, I think everything still selected has
polar interactions now.
The best way to show our modified binding
site is to hide all the sticks, then add back
the inhibitor and modified active site.
First, 6pfk, hide, sticks.
Now, let’s add the hydrogen bonding residues
back.
Inhibitor, show, sticks.
Binding, show, sticks.
Finally, click in the blank space to deselect
everything.
Notice this arginine is interacting through
its side chain, but we’re showing the entire
residue with its backbone atoms.
We can clean this up a bit more by just showing
the side chain.
And we can do this one or two residues at
a time, without saving the selection.
Click on the appropriate residues, sele, hide,
main chain.
Looking good!
We can delete this selection if we want now.
We want someone looking at our image to be
able to easily interpret it.
Let’s label the amino acid residues of the
binding site.
Binding, L, residues.
Ok, there they are, but some are super hard
to see.
We’re going to move them using edit mode.
To start, I remove all clipping, and find
a relatively unobscured view of the binding
site where all of the residues can be seen
clearly.
Now, zoom the binding site to let PyMOL add
its own clipping back.
Now, YOU NEED TO SAVE YOUR SESSION.
This is an essential save point.
You can completely mess up the protein in
edit mode, and you can’t undo it.
So, take a moment to save your PyMOL .PSE
session file.
Control save.
In the mouse controls, the mouse mode can
be changed from viewing to an editing mode
by clicking.
Now, if I press command on my Mac keyboard,
and click and drag on the labels, I can reposition
them.
But, if you accidentally click the protein,
you can move it, completely messing up the
structure!
So, I encourage you to save after each and
every label move.
Awesome job.
That’s a ton of work!
First, click on the mouse controls to exit
edit mode.
Now, save a scene of your hard work.
In the dropdown menus: Scene, store, F1.
Right click on the scene and rename it.
It’s really tricky to show an active site
without a protein loop getting in the way
or some poor looking clipping.
To be honest, I sometimes completely hide
the amino acid residues in a loop that’s
getting in the way.
I really like the context the cartoon gives,
but another strategy is to hide the cartoon
completely.
6pfk, H, cartoon.
Now, we can remove clipping completely, and
the active site resides just seem to float
there.
Let’s save a scene.
Now, you can toggle back and forth and choose
which scene you prefer, or try to modify further.
Thanks for watching this episode of PyMOL
101.
Next time, we’ll learn about the measurement
wizard.
If you’re enjoying this series, please subscribe
to my channel.